The biggest misconception about
redundancy, and perhaps challenge,
is a natural one and it's that
we all take it personally.
Redundancy is usually just a reality
where organisations are having
to reorganise and rethink
how they do things.
The more you can focus on
what makes you brilliant
and then find the next possibility
that matches that brilliance,
the better.
On average in the UK around 40% of us
will experience redundancy,
at least once in our working lives.
And in my nearly 20 years of work,
it's already happened to me
a few times.
Start with your strengths.
Your strengths are
what make you distinctive
and how you add value at work.
And research shows that when we
use our strengths we are six times
more engaged and generally
more satisfied in our jobs.
If you need some help spotting your
strengths try asking friends, family,
and people you've worked with
this question.
What three words would you use
to describe me at my best?
This will give you a quick insight
into the positive impact
that you have on others.
And once you know your strengths,
don't forget to make sure
they stand out on your CV
and on your LinkedIn profile.
Being made redundant
and searching for new opportunities
can be tiring, stressful,
and really overwhelming at times.
One useful technique
for staying optimistic
is to record and reflect
on all your very small successes.
At the end of each day
for at least a week,
write down one success
that you've had.
Perhaps it was just finding the time
to go for a walk
or supporting a friend in some way
or writing your first blog post.
Even if you've had a tough day,
this exercise helps us to reflect on
and recognise our positive progress.
Asking for help can feel hard.
So here are a few ideas, prompted by
what I've learned along the way,
about what works and just as
importantly, what doesn't.
First, don't apologize
and be specific about
the help that you need.
I remember being made redundant
and asking someone very senior
for career chat.
Within the first minute of our
meeting, she asked me,
"So how can I help you?"
And I was so grateful for her time
that I hadn't really thought about
a specific answer to that question.
And always avoid using words like
'sorry' and 'just'
in your messages and conversations,
it's important to be confident in
asking for the help that you need.
Second, think about how you feel
when you're helping someone.
You’re probably flattered and enjoy
the opportunity to be useful.
Remember, that's how
other people feel too.
And finally, if someone can't
help you, don't take it personally.
There's no limit on help,
so ask as many people as possible.
This advice has really helped me
to focus less on what I sometimes
describe as shiny objects,
like job titles or perks,
and prioritise making decisions
based on working with people
and at places
where I can learn the most.
I always remember Amanda's advice
in moments where
I'm feeling overwhelmed.
Fast forwarding to the future
helps me to be more pragmatic
and prioritise in the here and now.
It's easier than ever to compare our
careers to our family and friends
and colleagues,
but if we fall into this trap,
we forget that we're
all motivated by different things.
One of the advantages
of careers today
is that they can be as individual
as we all are.
So we need to invest in
and take care of our own careers.
I really hope this has been helpful
and very best of luck.